[Música]
más de 25.000 personas esperan en la
frontera entre Estados Unidos y México
para ingresar a territorio
estadounidense tras la expiración del
título 42 la administración biden impuso
un nuevo marco legislativo más
restrictivo
continúa el fuego en Alberta al oeste de
Canadá los incendios forestales arrasan
los bosques de la provincia y amenazan
una decena de comunidades indígenas en
una región con una alta actividad de
extracción petrolera
esta semana el ex líder para militar de
Colombia Salvatore mancuso pidió perdón
a sus víctimas y declaró ante la
jurisdicción especial para la paz contra
políticos y militares a quien acusó de
complicidad en sus crímenes tenemos
análisis en esta edición
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más relevantes
del continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
masdeu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles y abrimos en la frontera
entre Estados Unidos y México donde
miles de personas que esperan para
entrar a territorio estadounidense se
enfrentan a un marco regulatorio más
restrictivo Desde este pasado viernes
cuando expiró el título 42 y entró de
nuevo en vigor el título 8 y es que bajo
el nuevo marco legal la administración
biden mantiene las expulsiones
aceleradas y castiga los intentos de
entrada irregular con hasta cinco años
de veto en el país
entregarse a las autoridades en plena
medianoche como Irene una mujer
camerunesa de 38 años más de 25.000
migrantes se encuentran actualmente en
la frontera sur de Estados Unidos
No tengo otra opción mi vida está en
peligro
a lo largo de la última semana unas Diez
mil personas intentaron cruzar la
frontera de manera clandestina según las
autoridades de la nación americana esta
afluencia se produjo justo antes de la
expiración del título 42 una medida que
permitía la devolución inmediata de
todos los migrantes incluidos los
suristantes de asilo para hacer frente a
esta situación la administración
estadounidense endureció el jueves las
normas a partir de ahora antes de
presentarse en la frontera Los
solicitantes de asilo salvo los menores
no acompañados deberán obtener una cita
mediante una solicitud sino se pondrá en
marcha un procedimiento acelerado de
deportación y una prohibición de entrada
a Estados Unidos durante cinco años
la frontera ilegalmente porque sabemos
que hay hay una pena para eso Entonces
vamos a esperar un tiempo en la
aplicación Washington aún teme una
situación caótica y una afluencia masiva
en la frontera la administración biden
no hizo mucho porque es muy difícil
aportar una solución a lo que llamamos
los factores de incentivación es decir
lo que empuja a la gente a salir Por lo
general hay razones económicas la crisis
climática y la inseguridad en la
frontera la espera continua la medida
diseñada para centralizar la solicitudes
de asilo en Estados Unidos ya plantea
muchos problemas a los inmigrantes según
las asociaciones sobre el terreno las
franjas horarias son escasas solo el 10%
de los migrantes consiguen una cita
continuamos en Estados Unidos porque en
Carolina del Norte el gobernador Roy
Cooper Beto un proyecto de ley que
buscaba restringir el aborto a 12
semanas Luis Muñoz con los detalles
Beto a un proyecto de ley más
restrictivo con el aborto fue el derecho
que aplicó el gobernador de Carolina del
Norte Roy Cooper este sábado
con los obstáculos Y las restricciones
médicamente innecesarias el aborto no
estará disponible para muchas mujeres
particularmente aquellas con ingresos
más bajos aquellas que viven en áreas
Rurales y aquellas que ya tienen acceso
limitado a la atención médica por lo
tanto veto este proyecto de ley
testeo
el gobernador Cooper hizo una gira por
todo el estado para concienciar sobre la
necesidad de mantener la norma actual
que permite abortar hasta las 20 semanas
sin embargo a principios de mes los
republicanos que controlan las dos
cámaras del Estado aprobaron una ley que
restringiría los abortos después de 12
semanas además la ley estipulaba que los
médicos deben estar presentes cuando se
administra el medicamento y que las
mujeres que quieran abortar tengan una
consulta personal con un médico 72 horas
antes del procedimiento una forma de
disuadir que vengan mujeres de otros
estados este proyecto de ley ha tenido
la oposición de colectivos feministas el
aborto es atención médica y la autonomía
corporal es un derecho humano y la
prohibición del aborto de 12 semanas
viola eso con la mayoría que tienen los
republicanos en Carolina del Norte
podrían anular el veto del gobernador y
permitir que el proyecto se vuelva ley
próximamente
en el oeste de Canadá decenas de
incendios forestales continúan Arrasando
los bosques de Alberta una situación que
amenaza una decena de comunidades
indígenas y que ha llevado al gobierno
de la provincia a declarar el estado de
emergencia Alberta recordemos es una
zona petrolera donde según El Ejecutivo
solo en 2023
405 incendios forestales han destruido
cerca de 400.000 hectáreas previamente
analizamos las consecuencias de este
escenario con el analista Internacional
Ricardo almanza Guerrero
Sí definitivamente
el calentamiento global es un efecto que
se siente mucho más fuerte en este país
del norte de de continente y lo hemos
visto en los últimos años en este caso
estos incendios forestales en esta
provincia de Alberta lo comprueban las
temperaturas récord que se han tenido
por ejemplo netmo montón al inicio de
este mes de casi 29 grados fue una
primavera incitada con una sequía
también muy fuerte en el que
evidentemente el calentamiento global
los efectos de gases invernadero que se
están generando a razón de todo este CO2
emanado de los incendios pues tienen
estos efectos obviamente los efectos
climatilos climatológicos son muy
evidentes pero también los efectos
sociales y los efectos económicos ya que
como se menciona pues Alberta es una
región petrolera en el que se ha
disminuido no tan grave aproximadamente
no más de un cinco por ciento la
producción del petróleo no se han tenido
daños significativos en en las zonas
petroleras sin embargo está mermando
esta producción a razón de esta
prohibición de una mayor catástrofe es
un estado de emergencia que la primer
ministra
a razón de de solicitar la ayuda del
Gobierno Federal
creo que es un es Es evidente que se
está escalando y sobre todo que todavía
hay más de una veintena de incendios que
todavía no están controlados eso es
importante puntualizarlo porque pues
todavía no
esquema un esquema de certeza sobre este
tipo de incendios
y cerramos en Colombia porque hemos
tenido una semana con gran presencia de
Salvatore mancuso en la actualidad el
que fuera el líder de las temibles
autodefensas Unidas de Colombia tuvo
varios eventos en los que pidió perdón y
explicó Cómo operaban para analizarlo
tenemos a nuestro periodista Luis Muñoz
en el estudio bienvenido un gusto
acompañar la rosa y hoy sea cuéntenos de
qué trataron estos eventos Así es como
comentabas mancuso participó
virtualmente el martes en un evento en
Juan frío un corregimiento fronterizo
con Venezuela donde los paramilitares
utilizaron hornos crematorios para
desaparecer personas pidió perdón y se
ofreció a ir a Venezuela localizar los
desaparecidos de Colombia que yacen en
fosas comunes en el país vecino el
miércoles y jueves mancuso participó en
la audiencia única de verdad de la
jurisdicción especial para la paz el
tribunal es el resultado del acuerdo de
paz entre las FARC y el estado y le
hicieron una especie de examen para
determinar sus aportes son suficientes
para acceder a la justicia restaurativa
en estas dos primeras jornadas mancuso
dio detalles de las operaciones que su
grupo llevó a cabo así como las
conexiones con políticos fuerzas armadas
y empresas Rosa porque en esto en este
momento no estos actos de Reconciliación
y verdad este próximo lunes y martes
continuará con su relato Salvatore
mancuso Lleva más de 16 años en una
prisión de Estados Unidos ya ha
terminado condena pero no ha podido
salir por la emergencia de covid-19 está
a la espera de ser extraditado hay dos
opciones primera que vaya a Italia país
del que tiene nacionalidad y donde está
acusado por vínculos con La Mafia
calabresa la otra opción es que se ha
extraditado a Colombia donde tendrá que
enfrentarse a las acusaciones por miles
de crímenes eso significaría pasar el
resto de su vida en una cárcel
colombiana puesto que tiene 58 años su
aporte a la verdad podría abrirle la
puerta de la jurisdicción especial para
la paz la justicia restaurativa ofrece
reducciones de pena a cambio de verdad
con penas máximas de 8 años esa sería la
vía que estaría explorando el
excomandante de las autodefensas Unidas
de Colombia Rosa y pues muchas gracias
por esta explicación por este análisis
un gusto y a ustedes Muchísimas gracias
por su atención sigan con nosotros
[Música]